( music playing )
Alex: Good morning.
I'm bringing you some sad
and upsetting news.
- First and foremost...
- Mitch: I am a journalist.
I can feel when
the world needs me.
Alex: Because guess what.
America loves me.
Bradley: I'm just here
to deliver the news to America.
That's-- that's
all I ever wanted to do.
Cory:
People get their horrible news
delivered to the palm of their hand.
Alex: Don't you ever
question my integrity
in my own house again.
Mitch: I feel that people
are screaming
for an honest conversation.
Alex: I can guarantee that you
are underestimating me.
Bradley: I-- I think they want to know
the person behind the facade.
- Mitch: I have to fight back.
- Alex: You're not listening!
- Bradley: I push. It's just in my nature.
- Alex: You are part of this family.
- Alex: I don't need to justify anything.
- Bradley: And they all want to be right,
- and they all want to win.
- Cory: Well, that's just the world it is.
- Alex: We are doing this my way.
- Bradley: I think they want to trust
that the person is telling them
the truth about the world
is an honest person.